so anyway in conclusion the best thing
kevin feige did was making cowboys and
aliens starring john
i'm here with tom and nina to ask the
question what are the best and worst
decisions
kevin feige has made with the mcu nina
wanting to start us off
thanks brian um so wurst is tough
because as you said like most of these
movies are pretty good they've performed
really
spectacularly well at the box office
they're critically
like for the most part i mean avengers
infinity war and end game did very
very well with critics many of the
smaller ones have as well
so i think wurst is is tough and it's
very relative when it comes to kevin
feige running the mcu because he's done
a really good job it's hard
it's hard to find the bad stuff from
wrong but something that concerns me and
i'll admit that this is
i was uh when i was doing research for
this i stumbled across a piece written
by um
emily vanderworth who is i believe the
critic at large at vox
and she made a good point where she was
like the
mcu is the most television-esque thing
in film
right now in that sure you can watch the
movies by themselves but they're really
episodic
and if you watch captain america winter
soldier without having seen
the first captain america you don't
really understand why like
he is really anxious about government
oversight you know you don't really get
like the smaller kind of character beats
if you don't watch the entire thing
and i think that that level of
interconnectedness can be
can get really tricky because then you
start especially with so many movies i
think that a casual viewer might start
to feel alienated by the entire thing
and i think that that's
that concerns me going forward i mean an
example is like
you know during quarantine i lived near
my parents we watched a lot of movies
together
i couldn't have shown them infinity war
end game they would have been like who
are any of these people
because they don't watch marvel movies
but i could show them black panther
because it is a complete stand alone
and you can understand that movie really
really well without even though claw is
in other movies you don't need to know
who he is beforehand
you don't really need to know who he is
during either no and you don't and
even if you haven't seen captain america
civil war and the introduction of
t'challa you don't really need that
either
you just know when this movie opens if
his father has passed away right
so i think the interconnectedness is a
great strength but it could be a
weakness and that i think it could
alienate
um more casual viewers who don't want to
watch 20 plus movies to understand
what's going on
well i agree with you in theory i think
that obviously it's daunting right like
if i like
if i really like i really really like
captain america winter soldier and i
yeah
i want to say to someone hey let's watch
winter soldier yeah you'll be like
well do i need to see any other movies
to understand it and i'll be like
yes right but at the same time
i guess i guess that that weakness is
also the whole franchise's strength
because it's driven
everybody to see every one of these
movies
that's true but as you know phase four
continues and there's so much more and
there's tv shows
i mean i don't know what casual viewer
could have wandered into falcon in the
winter soldier without
having seen like every other movie even
as someone who's seen all the marvel
movies i still sometimes was like
wait who what i mean even i got a little
bogged down
um but and then quickly i think the best
thing um and i think we talked about
this in
in our chat at some point and it was
something that i brought up i think
something he's done that's really smart
uh is bringing in like smaller
directors who it's he brings in a lot of
television directors so like the russo
has worked on shows like
happy endings and arrested development
and then he was like do you want to helm
some of the biggest installments in this
entire thing and they
crushed it i mean the russos did a great
job with civil war and infinity war and
end game
so i think that and you know way before
chloe zhao was out there winning
academy awards he tapped her to direct
eternals
so i think he has a really good sense of
who should help which story
and whose sensibility is right and i
think he has
done a good job at picking people who
are less well-known but perfect for the
job
instead of just being like hey steven
spielberg or whatever do you want to do
at mcu movie
right not that would be bad but it's
just nice to see him giving a chance to
like
people who you don't know as well and
making them household names
if i could pick up the baton run with it
before we throw to tom that is also very
similar to my
best and worst decision so for me one of
the worst decisions he's made and i
guess you know i'm
i'm speculating here about what actually
was his decision but as the boss i'm
gonna assume that most of it fell to him
was when edgar wright left ant-man
yeah and so that you know edgar wright
is an amazing director
he's every film he's done is very good
to
extremely good you know even if even if
one of the movies that he did is not
your favorite or has some issues here or
there
overall it's still better than most
other movies
he also has carved out such a
distinctive style in like the vein of
west anderson where it's like if you see
five minutes of an edgar wright movie
you know that it's an edgar wright movie
immediately
yeah so while i really liked ant-man and
ant-man 2 i really like peyton reed's
work
the director of those movies i think
he's cool i think he's great i still
really would have loved to have seen
edgar wright yes i think that would have
been
amazing was that a creative differences
problem is that what happened
yeah something like that it's basically
just kind of um
it's never really been made clear what
happened or why
it happened that way but yeah creative
differences is generally what's
so you're saying that letting edgar
wright slip through his fingers was
kevin foggy's
biggest mistake i feel like doing things
to keep him happy
would have ultimately made for a really
memorable and exciting
movie right like yeah james gunn
guardians of the galaxy that's james
gunn movie
and then the the next one i was going to
say that one of the best decisions he
made was after that he got taika ytti
to revitalize thor yes and get thor
ragnarok
on the track that it was on and that's
one now like it
went from a franchise i didn't really
care about the thor franchise
to one of my absolute not only just
favorite mcu movies but
thor ragnarok is one of my favorite
movies in recent memory
and by getting tiger on board he got
natalie portman back into the mcu
i don't think she would have signed on
had like she'd not seen a totally
different vision for this character in
the story
yeah there's new and interesting things
happening yeah so many of these mcu
movies as much as i enjoy them for what
they are like the bare bones like hey
they're superheroes fighting like
i like them when they're interesting and
different and weird so
and the way that you've brought up the
guardians is a james gunn movie thor
ragnarok is a tycho ytt movie i mean if
you're familiar with
jojo rabbit or what we do in the shadows
it has that same very dry sensibility
he's got a great sense of humor so it's
they let him just
play around and you know figure out a
new direction
so yeah that's that's my best and worst
where the worst was
early on edgar wright getting away when
that could have been the start of really
cool stuff and kind of right but you
know best
learning from that mistake and then
starting to write the ship with
people like james gunn and tycho att
right so
those are my picks tom what about you
what are your
best and worst decisions that kevin
feige has made with the mcu
i totally agree i think it's kind of
remarkable especially with something as
big as
the mcu became this guy overall
and i wasn't there i don't know but from
what i understand really trusted
the creative people that he was hiring
you know he
knew that these people were good at
something for a reason
and uh so like even going back to iron
man you read about
uh john favreau going up to bat to bring
robert downey jr
on board studio maybe wanted somebody a
little bit less
could be found in the ditch at any
moment you know right
right well i think i circulate i found
that screenshot
from a very popular entertainment site
from 2009 that said like
marvel takes a chance on two no names
for thor and it was tom hiddleston and
chris hemsworth
right right yeah yeah and now they're
like
oh okay just two of the biggest movie
stars on the planet right
fine and that's that's another thing
like he
he found these uh these pretty great
direct like people who
who fit with what he was trying to make
right especially back at the beginning i
mean i
i know that the first thor movie is
nobody's favorite anything
but getting a shakespearean director to
try and handle these
like a good point yeah well and uh and
then going to captain america the first
captain america which was directed by
chris columbus no no it was against
the rocketeers the guy who did the
rocketeer i want to say
his name is it starts with joe excuse my
my
that's it joe johnston i didn't have to
type on my keyboard which i have a very
quiet keyboard i got it
good job well then i'm going to go to
you for facts yeah
um but tom it's really interesting that
you bring up jean favreau too
because like has there been anyone more
prolific in terms of directing and
creating stuff that we all like than
john favreau like
he did he kicked off the emcee with iron
man he didn't mandalorian
like he made zethura
well sure is that like not at all
is that a point in your in his favor i
never saw him yeah i haven't i just
assumed
that we were all in teams i'm very
flexible about a movie i haven't seen
a better question is are you team
cowboys or team aliens
cause he also directed cowboys and
aliens how can you ask me to choose
between my children in such a way
[Laughter]
i love them both in different ways i
actually heard that movies
i heard that movie is really good but i
still haven't gotten away i think it's a
really
fun action movie like not everything
needs to be an oscar winner it can just
be fun and
kind of dumb i'd watch it tomorrow if i
knew
any way to watch it without paying money
for it exactly
yeah so that's really brave of you to
say brian i know i'm taking a stand here
and now cowboys and aliens i want to
watch you but i don't want to pay for it
but just not for money it's not for well
not for more money
money i'm already paying yeah you want
to watch the movie but not
that badly i don't want to like pay
three dollars
actually i would pay 300
you wouldn't buy it for 15 but i think
you'd rent it for three
i really enjoyed the emotional journey
that you're going on right now i'm just
trying to find my floor and ceiling
for my desire to watch cowboys and
aliens starring daniel craig and
harrison ford
i presume as a cowboy and as an alien
i didn't realize that's who starred in
that movie now i have to watch it now
you have to watch it right i have to
i can't resist which one is a cowboy and
which one is an alien
if harrison ford's not a cowboy i'm not
watching the movie but what if he's a
cowboy alien what if they've come
together at the end and they're like
actually the aliens were cowboys the
whole time
actually the cowboys and aliens were the
friends we made
that's right the friends we heard along
the way pitching the plot of a movie
that came out ten years ago pretty
hard right now and then at the end
they're like this is so
money and then it cuts to black
john favreau a film by john favreau
and then the end is just then the end is
just uh it's just
outtakes from him on friends oh my god
i was standing i'd pay four dollars to
rent this movie
well i'm glad we made up the plot to a
movie none of us
yeah i don't know what we did here today
but i'm glad we did it
so anyway in conclusion the best thing
kevin feige did was making cowboys and
aliens starring john
the centerpiece the crown jewel of the
mcu yeah
it's the movie we all want to watch
marvel paid a billion dollars
yeah if marvel put out cowboys and
aliens it would make a billion dollars
yeah i probably would
it is based on a comic book the story
behind that i don't i don't know all the
details but i'm pretty sure
that the person who made that comic book
specifically did it so that he could get
a movie option
i mean also i think marvel could put out
like an andy warhol style video of like
robert downey jr sleeping for eight
hours and it would make a billion
dollars
i'd probably go watch it it would be it
would be great anyway
yeah yeah i'd watch it what does that
guy get up to when he's this thing
what does he do probably not much but i
gotta know
thanks for joining us please hit like
and subscribe so you don't miss a single
new episode